GURUPIAH MURSIB: The conformity
of contemporary architecture
worldwide and the inherent
loss of local identities
is a paradox of the century.
Hello.
My name is Gurupiah, and I'm
from the MIT-UTM Malaysia
Sustainable Cities Program.
In this video, I'll be
presenting the significance
of local involvement
in continuing
architectural identity within
rapidly globalized cities.
Malaysia is experiencing
rapid development
from little villages
into mega cities, steered
by a series of grand
transformation plans,
such as the 2020 vision.
One consequence of
rapid development
is the disappearance of local
architectural values embodied
in the functional built
form, the living culture,
and their relationship
with the environment.
The transformation of Malaysian
local architectural identity
can be seen in
government-led developments
and is epitomized by the new
federal administrative center,
Putrajaya.
There and elsewhere, the
government's attempts
to define identity
through architecture
have been characterized
as top-down and exclusive
in approach.
Instead of elevating Malaysia's
local architectural traditions,
the top-down approach
to asserting identities
turns to lead to mimicry or
copying of architectural styles
from other parts of the world.
Meanwhile, some attempts
for a local identity
are trapped in
prestige and parody.
The challenge of
preserving local identity
poses several questions.
How do we ensure the continuity
of architectural identities
in the face of
rapid development?
Would a more inclusive approach
to the formation of identity
be the way forward?
One project that exemplifies
the struggle of a local identity
in Malaysia is Kota
Iskandar, the Johor new state
administrative center, located
outside Johor Bahru, the state
capital.
Intended as the economy catalyst
project for Iskandar Puteri,
the site for Kota Iskandar was
offered by a land developer UEM
Land, a joint venture between
this state of Johor and UEM
Land was created.
A jointly appointed
property developer
was entrusted to design,
build, and manage the project.
Working within tight budget,
time framework, work on site
began in 2004 and was
completed in 2008.
UEM Lands' development
strategy for Kota Iskandar
was dominated by
outside consultants.
The criteria of having
strong project references
and proven track record
sidelined local consultants.
For the master plan process,
the only local involvement
was a user requirement survey.
No engagement with
local professionals.
the local community.
No design competition.
And no public forum.
These were not
required by contract,
and involved more time
and cost to execute.
Although stakeholder
workshops were held,
but did not provide any real
opportunity to offer feedback
on the design of the buildings.
The urban design and
architectural concept guideline
made it clear that this project
was intended to showcase
Johor's cultural heritage.
Johor's two main leaders, the
Chief Minister and the Sultan,
had different
design preferences.
Committed to preserving
local identity
through cultural heritage,
the Chief Minister
had traditional Johor
architecture in mind.
The Sultan of Johor,
on the other hand,
suggested we get to [INAUDIBLE]
administrative building
as the reference
for Kota Iskandar.
Designed by a British
consultant in 1942,
the building is an Anglo-Indian
structure with traces
of various Islamic styles.
But to avoid the stigma
of colonial architecture,
the design team and several
state governments' officials
made a study tour to
the Alhambra Palace
in Spain, a 14th century
Moorish-Andalucian heritage
site.
The resulting Kota
Iskandar master plan, this,
compromise of two identities.
First, a
Moorish-Andalucian identity
for the central axis,
which includes the state
legislative assembly building,
and the state secretariat
office, and the main plaza.
Second, a Johor
traditional identity
for the state office complex
is at this site clusters.
The Moorish-Andalucian
identity came up
off a process that was
top-down and exclusive.
All the projects
were exclusively
awarded to the architect
member from the master planning
team who was a non-local.
There was no base selection.
There was no opportunity
for local engagement.
There was no local feedback.
For the Johor
traditional identity,
the process was more
inclusive and locally engaging
because the chief minister
asked for involvement
from local consultants.
One local consultant submitted
[INAUDIBLE] that were twice
rejected because his track
record and project references
were not comparable
to a larger firm's.
To overcome this obstacle,
he formed a joint venture
with another passionate
local consultant.
To understand the local
value and aspiration
in forging identity, the new
team sold out a heritage expert
from a local university.
In comparison, a
process that led
to Johor traditional
identity was more inclusive
and locally engaging.
It engaged a local consultant.
It was a joint venture
with a local partner.
It saw the local
heritage expert.
It studied local design values.
The outcome of the
top-down down and
exclusive Andalucian identity
is impressively grand,
but foreign to Johor.
A tower mimics
that of [INAUDIBLE]
but has pseudo-Andalucian
detailing, and copies
of Alhambra arches and columns.
MOHD TAIUDDIN RASDI: Now
here in the modern times,
we simply take things
at its end form.
And so a building,
like the Alhambra,
supposed to represent great
Islam, so we just transplanted.
I wouldn't even use
the word replicating,
it would be like copying
something from the past.
And I think it's too much
of a copy, of an imitation.
GURUPIAH MURSIB: The
uncritical direct copy
of foreign identity results
in designs unsuitable
for the local climate.
What do we see?
Huge skylights, too hot for
Johor's equatorial climate,
which require costly
technology to reduce heat gain.
Courtyards that are made
of heat radiating surfaces.
Gardens without shade.
Vast open space makes for an
unbearable sun-baked plaza.
CHAU LOON WAI: If we really
consider our tropical climate,
which is generally
warm and humid.
So if we want to make places
comfortable for people,
then this needs to be really
taken into consideration
in the design in how we
arrange buildings, in how we
plant trees, provide shading.
GURUPIAH MURSIB: Even though
these foreign forms produced
unsuitable design
for the climate,
they prevail in Malaysia's
administrative and public
architecture.
By contrast, the more
inclusive and locally engaging
process for capturing
local identity
translates Johor
identity in modern forms.
RA'ALAH MOHAMAD:
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
GURUPIAH MURSIB:
Reinterpreting local identity,
as opposed to adopting
foreign styles,
pave the path to cultural and
environmental sustainability
today.
THE design creates functional
contemporary forms,
accommodates the social
features for office culture,
and responds symbiotically
to the environment.
A-frame porches make friendly
and welcoming entryways.
Multi-level verandas cater
space for meeting and greeting
under generous roof shade.
Common lobby features
drama of traditional farms
in space and volume.
Layered roofs allow
greater ventilation
and frame a visual experience.
Delightful overhangs provide
ample weather protection.
And craft tradition
extended expressive
contemporary detailing.
The Chief Minister, the
approving committee,
the master planner, and most
of the professional community
were impressed.
Inclusive engagement
and design methodology
were quickly adopted as a
benchmark for the remaining
design puzzles.
Comparison between the
two identity processes
in Kota Iskandar shows the
importance of local value
and the role of
local involvement
in continuing local identity.
Here are some key lessons.
Include local consultants
and local experts
to allow for deeper
intrinsic attitude
and approach in
incorporating local values.
Practice, a transparent
and open-bid process,
to promote competitiveness and
to prevent design complacency.
Consider local
citizen involvement
for sense of commitment
and attachment.
In order to reflect the culture
and values of the population,
planning process must move
from exclusive to inclusive.
This is vital for cultural and
environmental sustainability
in developing cities today.
It is our responsibility to
make sure our cities do not
end up looking the same.
Help preserve our local
heritage and values.
[MUSIC PLAYING]